a continuación los invito a que
repasemos las noticias destacadas de la
pandemia en américa latina'
las principales ciudades de colombia
comienzan desde este lunes y hasta el 19
de abril un nuevo ciclo de restricciones
para enfrentar el tercer pico de la
pandemia después de que miles de
personas viajaron en semana santa los
mandatarios locales deberán omitir los
decretos con toques de queda y también
restricciones de actividades dependiendo
de la ocupación de las unidades de
cuidados intensivos
pasamos a brasil país que roza los 13
millones de casos de kobe 19 y enfrenta
el peor momento de la pandemia este
domingo el país se registró 30 mil 359
contagios en las últimas 24 horas
descendieron las muertes diarias a 1.240
pero las autoridades han reiterado que
las cifras suelen ser más bajas fines de
semana debido a la falta personal para
registrar los datos
y venezuela registró en las últimas 24
horas mil 786 casos de kobe 19 lo que
supone el número más alto hasta el
momento y cerró la peor semana de la
pandemia en el país azul informó la
vicepresidenta ejecutiva de si rodríguez
desde el comienzo de la pandemia en el
país 164 mil 516 personas se han
contagiado de al menos mil 644 al muerto